apple a présenté sa nouvelle montre
connectés
la apple watch série scan
et franchement je trouve vraiment
intéressante à la déjà un design qu'un
petit peu revu et corrigé on reste un
peu dans l'esprit de la apple west
classic un écran qui cette fois ci
légèrement incurvé qui est 35% plus
large sur un modèle en 40 mm qui es 32%
plus large sur un modèle en 44 mm
néanmoins vous regardez quand même des
bords noirs sur le côté si je veux ce
sont des contraintes techniques cela
coûtait très cher ou être très compliqué
d'avoir tout un cadran tactile néanmoins
design est quand même plutôt cool c'est
vrai qu'avec le nouveau match os le
design a été repensé vous avez la
possibilité d'avoir des raccourcis
directement dessus soit de mettre vos
amis préférés vos recettes préférées
pour les appelés juste en un clic soit
de mettre des indicateurs de performance
soit de mettre des raccourcis pour votre
mot sport sont rajoutés les différentes
horloges avec différents fuseaux
horaires si vous êtes dans un besoin de
business si vous voyagez beaucoup en
tout cas c'est plutôt pas mal c'est
beaucoup plus personnalisable et ça
c'est un très bon point on a donc un os
qui est beaucoup plus graphique par
rapport à ce qu'il y avait avant
on a également des haut parleurs qui
sont à 50 % plus puissants par rapport
aux générations précédentes
un micro qui était écarté et des haut
parleurs pour éviter un effet de
résonance et des colorants vos appels
téléphoniques
une molette avec un touché haptique ça
c'est pareil le tue sympathique c'est un
peu compliqué de vous expliquer mais
faut vraiment le sentir que vous allez
vraiment ressentir les crantage au
niveau de votre doigt par rapport à ce
que vous allez voir sur votre écran donc
ça permet d'être toujours plus en lien
avec ce que vous avez à l'écran vous
avez la nouvelle puce s4 à l'intérieur
il faut retenir juste qu'elle est quand
même beaucoup plus puissante plus
performante que ce qu'il y avait sur les
ape watch series 3 pour moi il ya deux
points essentiels qui ont vraiment été
améliorée qui ont vraiment repris mon
attention sur cette montre tout premier
point c'est l'amélioration de
l'accéléromètre et le gyroscope et c'est
un peu le le cas d' usage qui était mis
en avant par apple c'est à dire que lors
de chutes
on peut paraître bête mais jamais
pourquoi je tomberai je suis pas
forcément bourré tout le temps je vais
encore même pas pourquoi est ce que
j'irai tomber mais c'est en
réfléchissant je me suis dit mais au
final c'est hyper mal de la part d'apple
parce que ça va permettre d'élargir
complètement leur cible parce que
l'apple watch à la base elle est
destinée aux personnes connectées dont
quatre personnes qui veulent des montres
connectés qui veulent se connecter à
leur smartphone pour des besoins de
sport beaucoup mais aussi qu'ils aiment
bien les petits gadgets quelles
nouvelles technologies ça c'est le coeur
de cible de la paix watch est là avec
cette amélioration et ce nouveau cas d'
usage il ouvre carrément alors s'il
s'adresse à certaines personnes peuvent
avoir certaines pathologies en tout cas
des problèmes musculaires ou des
problèmes neurologiques peuvent
entraîner des chutes
je pense notamment je vous prends
l'exemple le plus fréquent les personnes
âgées peut paraître un petit peu
déconnant de se dire on va collègues
d'apple watch une aimé et pourquoi pas
au final ça peut être vachement
intéressant parce que les explique
qu'effectivement avec votre appel watch
vous êtes par exemple comme ça vous fait
une chute à l'avant
vous allez jeter vos mains devant pour
vous rattraper donc ils vont savoir que
vous tombez à la vente
vous allez aussi avoir la chute vers
l'arrière donc hop que vous mettez comme
ça vous allez avoir les mains pour
essayer de vous rattraper votre père
votre équilibre et vous avez aussi la
chute à la verticale pour le coup la
chute à la verticale c'est à dire qu'il
ya un vrai black out au niveau du
cerveau animal avant ni les mâles
arrière vous tombez comme une grosse
patate et ça c'est vraiment intéressant
parce que jamais vraiment d'illustrer
des problèmes de santé et l'apple watch
et là en tout cas pour vous aider et
pour comprendre un peu ce qui s'est
passé et autre point très intéressant et
c'est là où on voit qu'ils sont vraiment
balèze et qui sont vraiment bien capter
leur sujet c'est de se dire dès que la
personne tombe tout fils d'autres
smartwatch va téléphoner pour appeler
les urgences donc ça veut dire que vous
avez soit un modèle cellulaire avec une
carte sim à l'intérieur qui est
compatible uniquement chez orange pour
l'instant en france en tout cas qui vous
permettra donc d'appeler directement les
services de secours au secours je suis
tombé et me rejoindre
ou alors directement relié à votre
smartphone donc ça c'est vraiment un cas
l'usaf qui est très intéressant et qui
permet en tout cas vraiment de
s'adresser un tout nouveau public
le deuxième point c'est super
intéressant c'est le côté médecine
prédictive sont pas utiles médecine
préventive en accueillant tout ça
notamment lié aux maladies
cardiovasculaires
c'est à dire que vous aviez
effectivement et votre apple doivent
déjà un capteur qui vous permet de
capter les rythmes cardiaques de savoir
à combien table votre coeur donc
effectivement permettra d'aller toujours
plus loin il y aura des alertes par
exemple si vous allez avoir un coeur qui
t'a beaucoup trop vite vous dire
attention oulala vous avez le coeur qui
tu es vite c'est surprenant le coeur qui
tape moins vite attention vous pourriez
avoir des problèmes cardiovasculaires
aller consulter un médecin vous avez par
une arythmie votre coeur qui bat de
façon irrégulière
allez consulter un médecin vous pouvez
avoir un problème cardiovasculaire et en
plus de ça et là où ils sont très forts
et c'est vraiment hyper pertinents ils
ont rajouté au niveau de la molette
deuxième capteur rythme car direct au
bout de vos doigts et avec ça avec les
deux capteurs ils vous font un petit
électrocardiogramme un petit ecg et ça
c'est plutôt pertinent alors même si
vous n'allez pas avoir le résultat idéal
comme sur un nuage et qu'on pourrait
vous faire directement à l'hôpital
néanmoins ça peut être vraiment bien
pour avoir un suivi lorsque vous avez
des problèmes cardio vous allez ensuite
pouvoir transmettre si vous le souhaitez
et bien évidemment les donner à votre
médecin pour pouvoir être mieux suivi
est mieux soigné
ça vous permettra aussi de repérer tous
les risques
tous les problèmes de rythme cardiaque
directement grâce à vos twh ça pourrait
vous éviter d un fart enfin différents
problèmes et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant et c'est vraiment très très
très malin parce que la cible du coup
d'apple qui était vraiment basé sur les
amoureux de technologie et puis les
sportifs souffre a carrément parce que
maintenant elle s'adresse à tout le
monde à tout le monde à tout âge pour
essayer de sauver tout sur le problème
et ça vous allez voir ça va vraiment
évolué dans les années à venir va y
avoir encore plus de capteurs dans vos
monde connecté et dont tous vos
appareils pour aller toujours plus loin
au niveau de la santé predicted la
médecine prédictive ça ça m'intéresse
énormément
donc on va continuer à en parler
pourront bien évidemment vous avez le
calcul de calories tout ce qui concerne
le sport est inclus directement dans
votre apple watts pour les sportifs peut
toujours aller beaucoup plus loin
ça c'est plutôt cool apple a vraiment
fait un focus sur une protection des
données en disant attention vos données
avec nous son protégé elles risquent pas
de partir je ne sais où on sait que
apple c'est toujours un peu la guerre
avec facebook par rapport à la
protection des données
donc l'appoint cours de ils veulent
vraiment dit attention vous achetez des
produits apple avec nous c'est hyper
safe vous ne risquez absolument rien au
niveau de la batterie apple nous annonce
une apple watch serris 4 avec une
batterie sur une journée complète donc
une montre à eau charges et tous les
jours c'est une mode connecté qui est
disponible en argent en enrayant gris et
quelques solides à 429 euros et si vous
voulez le modèle cellulaire
il vous en coûtera 5 129 euros à noter
que l'appel aux world series 3 baisse en
prix elle passe à 299 euros au modèle
classique et à 399 euros en modèle c'est
lui là voilà tout simplement en tout cas
parce que c'est vraiment très
intéressant de voir un petit peu de
quelle manière des grandes marques comme
apple prennent en main
les problématiques de santé collecter de
santé prédictive tout ça vraiment très
intéressant je vous invite une fois de
plus à rester connectés parce que les
mondes connectés justement moi ça
m'intéresse beaucoup
j'en ai deux ici qu'on va tester très
rapidement j'ai la tique auch pro j'ai
aussi l'ami band 3 du chiot me on va
parler beaucoup beaucoup des mondes
connectés
j'ai la samsung galaxy watch qui arrive
qui devrait arriver demain normalement
donc vous allez voir on va en parler
c'est super cool merci à vous d'être
toujours plus nombreuses sont plus
nombreux on va beaucoup parler d'apple
on va tester ses nouveaux iphone on va
essayer tester cette walsh rs4 ferment
possible pour la récupérer dont vous
invite à faire une seule chose c'est à
vous abonner et à la totalité d'ici là
soyez sages vous embrasse tous
[Musique]